LYLA FUJIWARA: You need to
run background processes,
whether it's syncing with the
server for the freshest content
or crunching data for your app.
However, running
background processes
leads to a tricky compromise
for the operating system.
Even if 20 apps have requested
very important background work,
the app that the user is
actually interacting with
needs to run smoothly.
Android Oreo introduces
a radically different way
to think about
background services.
Apps cannot run freely
in the background.
This has implications
for apps launched
from an implicit
broadcast, as well as
apps starting services
in the background.
Here's a quick list
of affected APIs.
Location APIs are also
affected, but I'm not
going to be covering these now.
More details on location
updates are in the notes below.
These changes are true
for all apps targeting
O. But even if you
don't target O,
users can turn these
limitations on,
so you need to be aware
of these changes anyways.
First on the list of background
behavior changes are services.
Calling start service
from the background
will cause an illegal
state exception.
Now this does not
affect services started
when your app is visible
and in the foreground,
nor does it affect
bound services.
Here are a few more
situations where the app is
considered in the foreground.
When your app moves from the
foreground to the background,
there is a short grace period
before your services shut down.
The service shuts down as
if it had called stop self.
Now these changes affect
everything that is a service.
So are IntentServices affected?
Well, yes.
Are Pending services affected?
Not when they are created, but
when they are sent, so yes.
This even affects services
you start in the background
that you intend to
promote to the foreground.
The good news is that
there are a few options
for saving your services.
Unless your app is
an alarm clock app,
90% of the time your best option
is to replace your background
service with a scheduled job.
While you are no longer
allowed to start services
in the background,
job scheduling
could do background
work on your behalf.
This allows the
framework to take
all of the scheduled jobs and
their different constraints
and figure out which
jobs to run when.
There are a number of different
solutions for job scheduling
depending on your apps' needs.
I've linked to the documentation
which explains the tradeoffs,
but if you want
my advice, I would
look into using Firebase
JobDispatcher and the new Job
IntentService.
Job IntentService is especially
handy to replace IntentService.
Next is the temporary
service whitelist.
There are a few special
cases listed here
where the app will be
temporarily whitelisted
and act for a short
period of time
as if it's in the foreground.
If you want to trigger work
when data on the server changes,
consider implementing Firebase
Cloud Messaging on your server
and app.
If used a high
priority FCM message,
you will receive that
message immediately
even with the system is in Doze.
You will also get on that
handy service whitelist
so you could start a
service as if the app were
in the foreground.
Now if it's a normal
priority FCM message,
the message is delivered when
a user turns the device screen
on or during the Doze
maintenance window.
You are not whitelisted
to start services though.
So if your app receives both
high and normal priority
messages, one approach is
to try starting the service,
and if for any
reason that fails,
have a fallback, such
as starting a job.
If the service is
something the user might
interact with or
want to monitor,
you can make a foreground
service instead.
Foreground services have
a persistent notification
onscreen which informs the user
that they're actually running.
Timers and navigation
apps are common examples
of apps that employ foreground
services effectively.
The thing is the
old way of starting
a foreground service from the
background will no longer work.
Instead, switch to the new API
to start a foreground service.
The steps are first, use the
new start foreground service
method.
This creates a
background service
that you must immediately
promote to the foreground.
Within the service,
make a notification.
Your foreground
service notification
should always be
of low importance
or higher so that it's
actually visible to the user.
It should not be
of mid importance.
The final step is to have
the service promote itself
to the foreground using start
foreground and the notification
that you just made.
If you need a PendingIntent
to start a foreground service,
you can use PendingIntent's new
get foreground service method,
and then follow the
same steps to promote it
to a foreground service.
If none of those
options work for you,
you might consider
deferring your work
until your app is
in the foreground.
Now if you need to test your
app under the new restrictions,
I've also included links
below with the adb commands
to make the app run
in the background
and to force background
limitations for your app.
OK, let's switch to talking
about implicit broadcast
receiver limitations.
Broadcast receivers
that are statically
defined and listening
for implicit broadcasts
will not receive
those broadcasts.
Implicit broadcasts do not have
the target component attribute
set.
And static broadcast
receivers are defined
in the Android manifest.
Prior to Android Oreo,
implicit broadcasts
would trigger any component
listening for them
in the manifest.
Now, in research
constrained situations,
this would cause
memory thrashing
as a single broadcast
triggering the creation
of a bunch of different
components from different apps.
So here are your
options for replacing
static implicit
broadcast receivers.
Now there's a short
list of exceptions,
so you should absolutely
check that list first.
If the broadcast is on that
list, it won't be affected
and it will function as normal.
This list contains things such
as changing locale or plugging
in headphones.
The full document is linked.
If your broadcast is
not the exception list,
you might be able to
replace it with a job.
Jobs can be triggered by the
following conditions, some
of which have been added
in O. In particular,
content provider observers
could trigger jobs
for a variety of situations,
such as when the user saves
a new picture on their phone.
Now if part of
your app is already
running when the
broadcast is set,
you can switch to a dynamic
broadcast receiver instead.
This means moving your
broadcast receiver code out
of the manifest.
And then you create,
register and unregister
it during runtime
like I'm doing here.
Even though these situations
focus on background processes,
the benefits will
be felt for those
using your app in the
foreground-- with less
jank and fewer crashes.
This will be even more
impactful for users
who don't have access to the
most expensive or fastest
hardware.
I've touched on a number of
strategies and API changes.
If your app is
affected and you want
to learn more and get
started with code examples,
check out the documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]